my name is s'agit sati I'm director of
academic programs here at the Stanford
center for professional development and
I'm really excited to have you here
tonight we we have gathered a very
interesting group of people to share
information with you and we'll we'll
start by just taking taking listen and
getting started so I want to acknowledge
all the SCPD team members who are
working with colleagues and other teams
across the university with a single
purpose in mind and that is to give you
access to these classes that are offered
every quarter here at Stanford the
result this this autumn quarter
SCPD is offering sixty four classes to
remote students and we're excited to
have you here and join us if you look
around the room and as you get to know
your classmates later in our welcome
reception also know that you were part
of a group of more than 1100 remote
students are joining you this quarter
from around the world and all over the
country so on behalf of all of us at
Stanford congratulations on taking this
step in your education journey we're
really glad you're here our goal tonight
is to share with you the information
need to know to get the quarter off to a
good start our discussion will be mostly
Q&A with the panel of experts two
returning SCPD students a professor and
a TA all of whom will tell you simply
just the way it is but before we dive in
I want to introduce our keynote speaker
tonight computer science professor John
Mitchell John earned his bachelor's
degree at Stanford and his master's and
PhD degrees at MIT he joined Stanford as
a professor in 1988 and over the years
has published hundreds of articles and
collaborations and tours and advised
thousands of students John's first
research project in online education
started in 2009 when he and six
undergraduate students built Stanford
course where an innovative platform that
expanded to support interactive video
and discussion course were served as the
foundation for initial flipped classroom
experiments at Stanford and helped
inspire the first massive open online
courses better known as MOOCs from
Stanford that captured wall
while attention in 2011 since 2012 John
has served his vice provost at Stanford
most recently a device Provost for
teaching and learning under John's
leadership a CPD transition from the
School of Engineering to unit within VP
TL allowing SCPD to have a broader
impact in reach across the entire
university
after completing two terms as vice
provost John stepped down earlier this
year but before we started missing him
too bad in for real we were happy to
learn the in January he will become
chair of the computer science department
by far our largest collaboration in the
university so while he's no longer my
boss's boss's boss I'm still I'm still
working for him so with this in mind
please help me and give John Mitchell
and SCPD welcome thank you so I just
want to welcome you all here and
congratulate you on making the excellent
choice to listen to people like me and
believe what we say and go off and tell
other people because it's all true and
and we wouldn't teach you anything if we
didn't know it well here so I think this
program here has been very successful
many of you may not know much about the
history apparently in the School of
Engineering our distance education
programs date back to 1954 so that's
before I was born I have no idea what
they did in 1954 probably something on
paper in the mail or something like that
I don't know how they did distance
education 1950 oh I know in the 1970s we
had this kind of direct microwave TV
link to local companies Hewlett Packard
was one of the leading companies in the
valley at that time other companies
would subscribe and I was actually a
student here as I gave mentioned
sometime in that decade and what I
remember from a course that I took in
this building this right above this
auditorium is we would all
sit in the classroom and look at our
little screens and the person at the
front would talk at his little screen
and whenever there was a question
somebody else in the valley could push
their button at their sight in Milpitas
or Cupertino or someplace else in Palo
Alto and ask a question in real time so
the quality of some things has gone up
but we've kind of lost that interactive
and eye interaction with you if your
remote and I hope it'll come back
sometime in the time that you're
involved in this program I'm not quite
sure about that but I really liked that
interactive activity and I think that's
something we can hope for in the future
since the 1990s this has been web-based
delivery which has been very successful
so we we as I've mentioned offer about
200 courses a year from the School of
Engineering and otherwise in the format
that you're taking them and that's if
you were to count the number of students
enrolled on campus and where they're
enrolled in that's the bulk of the
student course hours in the School of
Engineering are all available to all of
you so I think that that's really
represents our commitment at Stanford to
reaching as many people as possible as
successfully as we can and you all look
bright and cheerful and energetic and so
I'm sure we're reaching the right the
right people as best we can there one
thing you might not know is that you
probably have the same experience
remotely as students on campus it turns
out that about 80 percent of the video
views for the courses that we deliver in
the form that you see them are from
students on campus so you might not see
it remotely but for most of us teaching
the room is empty and everybody is
remote so
you are following the most popular path
through Stanford by being remote
students you're in really good company I
don't know if you've been to the Huang
engineering building does anybody
recognize that it's the place where
there's a cafe and and stuff just over
behind this building Jenson Wang who was
the donor who's the building is named
after was a remote student he got a
master's student at Stanford and as far
as I know he never set foot on campus
during that time so you're on the path
to become a CEO of a company like Nvidia
if you want and if you're lucky a friend
of mine bill Dahle who used to teach in
our department has been the chief
scientist of Nvidia for maybe 10 years
and he told me an entertaining story
that I'm not going to repeat about
Jenson Wang being pulled over by the
California Highway Patrol for driving
his Ferrari too fast down the highway so
I wish you success if you have that kind
of success don't tell us but if you have
another kind of technical success around
your business or your your scientific
career we that we'd love to hear about
it the way you drive your Ferrari is
kind of your business
so please enjoy the courses I know that
they're they're challenging we try to
challenge everyone that's what we do for
a living
but work hard you know have fun learn
stuff and you know keep in touch you
know let us know when something is
successful when something isn't one of
the things I that I really appreciate
very much and it happens all too
infrequently is you know somebody a year
five years ten years after they took a
course will send me an email and say you
know that course I hated when I was a
student meaning my good course you know
it actually was very valuable and the
most important part to me was this that
I didn't appreciate it at the time but
I do you know that kind of thing is very
gratifying as a teacher we teach too you
know this big empty room and lots of
people on video so hearing from you is
valuable to all of us and I know as you
go forward in your careers and have the
success in the directions you choose you
know you're in your advice and and input
to us on what we could do better or what
topics we should cover or how we've been
helpful to you is very valuable isto so
please you know make good connections
with each other with other people in the
courses and programs you enroll in and
you know keep us informed of what
happens to you and where we've been
helpful to you and how we could be more
successful in reaching others so that's
basically my thought I don't know if
there any questions but I do appreciate
all of your interest in our programs we
work hard as second I said there's a big
organization here to try to deliver to
you the best possible experience we can
for people at a distance and from the
point of view of being on the faculty
here we feel very enthusiastic about our
fields we love our work we love our
topic area and we're really just very
pleased to be able to share that with as
many people as possible so please have a
good evening here enjoy meeting each
other and thank you for coming
[Applause]
perfect
thank you John let me share with you the
plan for the evening first I'm going to
briefly overview some of the key
information you need to know as the
quarter begins because all this
information is available online I'm not
going to go into a lot of details about
it it's it's on our web site the SCPD
website or the University website right
I do recommend it if anything I speak to
is something that is confusing not
familiar or new please be sure to ask
questions of our team later tonight and
as we go to our network receptions we
want to make sure that you have the
right information so after going over
the the short deck we will introduce our
panel team members will respond to your
questions now this is really cool and
this is our first time trying it but
it's been tested here so let's give it a
try I'm going to ask you to go to Paul f
dot-com slash SCPD on your on your phone
in start you have a choice to enter and
input a question that you would like to
ask the panel you also have the very
cool opportunity of up voting questions
that have already been submitted and by
you up voting the question it gives us
indication as to whether or not this is
of interest to a larger number of of
individuals and we'll try to to go
through the questions are of most
interest to the most people as best we
can the other cool thing about is do you
you can also vote down questions but we
don't do this here right it's
technically possible but it's not cool
so so please remember that and also our
tech team is appreciating your your
stress testing our Wi-Fi in the room and
I hope everybody will be able to connect
doing it before the quarter is better
then as the quarter begins and so let's
get started accessing course content
right so as we all know our quarter
begins next week next week is week one
the most important thing for you to do
is to access your course website and
identify
the platform in how to access the
lectures in the course go to the SCPD
website then click on the my Stanford
connection button log in and as you
complete your login process you'll get
to you essentially or your your
dashboard where the class or classes
you're taking will be listed right that
should provide information for you at
the very least to a to our video
platform our video platform and video X
is where recorded lectures are hosted do
not wait to receive a special invitation
from anyone right so this is just like
when you got your undergraduate degree
or any other graduate degree right
you're now a student in university
you're expected to find your classroom
even if it's a virtual classroom many
teaching teams will send out a welcome
email but but it's your responsibility
to go and find it information I do want
to mention that depending on the course
that you are enrolled in you will access
your course information either via a
canvas website canvas is a learning
management system in user or a website
or some other platform that information
is available to you after you login for
most classes that we offer here at SCPD
recorded lectures are also available in
near-real-time
by logging into canvas don't
stanford.edu you go to canvas with
stanford.edu you use your student ID to
sign in you get your dashboard with a
tile that you can click and access your
class so the nice thing about it is that
because classes are streamed in
near-real-time if you know for example
that your first class is on Monday at
9:30 and your schedule is open and work
and you can actually log into the system
and you'll be able to watch that first
lecture as it is given canvas is also
the place where recording of lectures
and and other sessions from the course
will be kept throughout the quarter so
definitely check that out real easy to
use we get fantastic reviews for that
system contacts any questions you have
about your course about your class the
best the best way to get an answer is
simply to contact the teaching team and
how to contact the teaching team will be
available on the class website any other
issues that are not real
to academic content or if you're not
sure please please do not hesitate and
contact our student and Client Services
team we're here to support you
especially during the first week of the
quarter so the one thing we don't want
you to do is you know don't hesitate
write ask us those questions exam
procedures very very important than you
you'll notice the red font right so
students in classes with in class
monitored exam must have an approved
exam monitor information about how to
get that process started is on the exam
section in Nice Stanford connection so
just log in and understand the process
understand how it works the autumn exam
monitor no nomination due deadline is
Monday October 8th so this is really if
there's one thing to take right is to
make sure understand the process you
know who can be a exam monitor and you
complete this process by October 8th any
delay in in doing this right increases
the likelihood of off of nearly needless
worrying about about stuff not happening
on time right so please please be sure
to take that action item that step
stanford honor code what is it
the stanford honor code is a set of
standards that establish the
expectations for academic integrity
required of all students and you are now
students in the university right if you
want to get I highly recommend Google
search Stanford honor code you will get
to the University website where all the
policies are detailed but in a nutshell
you're supposed to do your own work
you're not supposed to help others with
their work and and others are and and
vice versa right so so here are some
violations that I that I think are
interesting right and I collected these
from from prior classes the teaching
team in your class will also have
additions to this policy so looking at
previous year's homework solutions right
either official or written by another
student discussing homework prone right
so individual assignments are to be
completed individually
submitting malicious code right not an
honorable thing to do
it's a violation of the honor code and I
don't do it
uploading your code if you're if you're
dealing with computer code to a to a
public repository like github get the
violation and we have the systems in
place right so let's let's try and see
if if we have systems in place to to
identify this event I will say that the
process is a serious process a process
of honor code violation it is a very
fair process and in the few instances
where we have been involved we certainly
notice that there is a sincere effort on
the part of the university to make sure
that your site is heard the know the
policy course evaluations there are two
opportunities for you to give feedback
the first one will happen mid-quarter
will send to you via email the SCPD
mid-quarter survey it happens around
week five that survey is for us to
understand to make sure that everything
works right it is not a vehicle for you
to ask questions of the teaching team
and it's not a vehicle for you to ask
questions that are timely right we
receive hundreds of responses and while
we read through all those responses if
there's something timely there that you
need us to respond to might take us a
couple of weeks that's not the way to go
the University end of quarter evaluation
is available on the tenth and eleventh
week of the quarter very important to
complete that you do not want to cause
incompletion of it to cause any delay in
you getting your grades at the end of
the quarter important deadlines
important deadlines first day on
instruction is next week the drop
deadline is Friday October 12 before
5:00 p.m. Pacific time withdrawals and
grading basis changes November 16
incomplete requests December 7
assignments and exam are subject to your
2 plus syllabus right so you're all
working professionals most of you are
however work related travel or or heavy
workload generally speaking is not a is
not considered a sufficient
justification for skipping a deadline
right so at the same time we know that
life happens
when events outside your control happen
that it might cause you to miss a
deadline be diligent and inform the
teaching teams as early as you can and
do not hesitate to involve the student
services team also the earlier we know
the challenge did the earlier we have an
opportunity to help the last one at the
last item here I want to speak to his
tuition reimbursement right many of you
will receive tuition reimbursement from
your companies some companies because
because autumn quarter ends very near to
the end of December end of the year some
companies stopped processing this
request say on December 15th right your
responsibility is to understand the
policy at your company know if you have
any deadlines for submitting tuition
reimbursement requests in your company
and make sure that you know when will
degrades be available in certain cases
we can help you get your grades a few
days earlier but please let us know
about that in advance these are the
important policies right all of it is on
the website thank you for for for
listening as we review this I hope
you've been busily and entering and up
voting questions to poll EV dot-com /
SCPD so please take a moment think about
what we cover and I will now introduce
my colleague pax hammer will also bring
our panel of experts and will take us
through a what we hope is the heart of
the conversation tonight which is asking
questions right students professor a TA
an SCPD and so it's my pleasure to
introduce the panel tonight which is
made up of instructors and grad and
students here as part of the SCPD
program so I'll just invite them to come
up to the chairs up here front and
center well front into the side I
suppose and I'll introduce them as we go
through and then we'll come up with some
questions and then at the end I'll come
back to the questions that you'll be
posting and pull everywhere and direct
some of them to the panel
so first is Nick Turco Lee he's a
lecturer here in the computer
department at Stanford and before being
before teaching here he was a graduate
student he was also the lead TA for the
past two years for 106 ACS 106 a and CS
106 B and so this quarter he is teaching
CS 106 X and C in the fall and CS 107 in
the spring so as his role as sort of the
lead TA he oversaw a lot of logistics
for sebt these students and making sure
that your experience is really fantastic
so we're excited to have him here today
to share some of his insights we're also
really fortunate to be joined by Zahra
kucik who's one of our most experienced
TAS she's a fifth-year PhD students in
the electrical engineering department
and she's been a TA for some of our most
popular courses so machine learning deep
learning intro to linear algebra and
this this quarter she's part of the
teaching team for CS 229 machine
learning is that correct
fantastic so we're excited to have her
here and share some of her on insights
in addition to our two instructors we
also have two students so Colby Lopez is
currently part of our honors cooperative
program he's pursuing a part-time
master's and the management science and
engineering program he has a Bachelor
mechanical in bachelors in mechanical
engineering from Mississippi State and
he's working at Chevron he's been
working there for the past five years he
works in technical support for some of
the mechanical mechanical operations and
he's been work for Chevron he's worked
in Houston he's worked in Australia and
now he's working over in Richmond so
we're excited to have him here tonight
and next to Colby is to Shara Deut who
is it has a bachelor's in computer
science from Waterloo he has also has a
bachelor's in business administration
from Wilfrid Laurier University and he's
been part of the Google family for a
while so he starred in ads I hear that's
where everyone starts at Google and then
he moved on to let me see here you were
part of X the moonshot Factory and now
you're part of alphabets cybersecurity
startup locally in Mountain View and
like Colby to Shara's is part of a
honours cooperatives program and he's
pursuing a master's in computer science
with dual focus and artificial
intelligence and systems so we're really
excited to have
here today and I want I've got the
microphone so we'll just pass it back
and forth and I want to start with just
a high-level question here for Nick and
Zara
so both of you have a lot of experience
here working with students helping them
through so Nick I'll start with you just
at a high level what does it take to be
a successful student here at SCPD what
would be your high level advice to the
students here tonight
sure well thanks for having me I think
you know I've gotten the opportunity to
have a lot of experience teaching a CV
classes which has been a lot of fun and
I think the biggest thing I would
probably say is to engage with the
teaching staff as much as you possibly
can I think you know we certainly see
from my personal experience and from
other experiences from other teas and
instructors you know the more that
students on campus and remote engage
with their teaching team the better they
do in the class because they get more
responsive help they form relationships
with their TAS which is something that
you can absolutely do on campus but it's
certainly harder to do when you're a
remote student but as you communicate
with them you can get better feedback
you can you know get have more of a
back-and-forth conversation about ways
you can improve and so that would be
kind of my number one piece of feedback
is the teaching team is you know for
every team that I've been on has been
extremely eager and and interested to
hear feedback from every SCPD student
want to engage with them as much as
possible so you know I encourage you to
take advantage of that before you pass
on with just one question that's already
come up maybe as a follow up is who
should students be reaching out to first
is it the TA the CA the professor who's
best to make that first first outreach -
and and how soon should they do that
yeah it's a great question so I think
certainly there's a lot of benefit in
reaching out in the first week or two
for sure just to get some contact on the
teaching team to kind of get your
orientation a lot of classes for SCPD
organized the TA team to have certain
SCPD students assigned to certain
graders for instance that's a great
person to reach out to because they're
the ones that are going to be giving you
feedback on ways to improve and then
last but not least some classes have
specific SCPD TAS that they might make
available to you as well for office
hours or other questions so it really
depends on kind of the class
organization and the class size but for
the most part there are usually multiple
people that have different
responsibilities in relation to you and
it's definitely beneficial to reach out
to all of them thank you Nick
you could share some of your insight hi
I'm Zara and I'm very excited to be
again a CPD ta dis quarter so as Nick
said I just want to add one more thing
is that to be a successful sepds you
then I think it is important in addition
to try to connect to the TAS try to
connect to others CPD students for CS
two to nine in particular via we have a
site called Piazza make sure that you
log in to the Piazza very early in the
quarter this is like the most important
like question and answer source for
on-campus student and remoter students
so when you got a question just make
sure that this question is not already
asking Piazza and if it is a new for
everyone posted on Piazza and also
another good feature on the Piazza is
that it helps you to find like good
teammate for your class so basically
from my experience I was student here in
Stanford if you want to get the best
outcome of their Stanford courses
especially in the cs department is that
you find the teammates that have the
same concern as you working on the same
assignment same like project as you that
can help you to have the better
experience so it's not like you sit
alone at home and do your assignments
only by yourself so it's good to be in
connection with other students and have
they help so try to be connected to the
TAS and to the other students
specifically STP the other CPD students
that's that's fantastic advice and I
have a high level question for both to
char and Colby but maybe if you want to
build on that have either of you had
that opportunity to reach out and make
connections with other students at SCPD
and if so
could you talk about that yeah I stay in
conversation with quite a few SC BD
students especially those are in the HCP
program so one of the things that you
guys will probably experience there's a
lot of the SCP students like to use
what's called slack
it's a QuickTime messaging system kind
of like facebook Messenger so I was
actually just chatting with another SC
media student before this through slack
and we use that Avenue Piazza like she
was mentioning before and Skype or video
chat that's my experience with it yeah
there's a slack that I think a lot of
SCPD students are on and then there's
also just if you depending on what
companies you work on you might find
that there are some people in your
company already taking courses for SCPD
that might be how you were introduced to
it so you can reach out to them and also
you can just use Piazza or so on to meet
up with other CPT students so sure maybe
hold on the microphone and just could
you share so as Aaron and Nick offered
their sort of high level feedback what
would be your insights if you think back
to your first quarter here with SCPD I
mean what course were you taking and you
know what do you wish you had known
before you began in the program yeah so
my first quarter with SCPD I took I
can't remember the exact course number
of videos client-side web programming
essentially and it was really good I
actually think for your first course you
might want to consider taking it was a
lighter course it was a hundred level
course and so you might want to consider
taking something like that to kind of
gauge the workload and so on so I think
I was really helpful if not to start
with you know a heavier course and just
if I were to go back one of the things
would be you know in general you gotta
you have to think of all these courses
and your SCPD kind of career as more of
a marathon rather than a sprint so you
know try to if you if you take all the
intense courses all at once you know or
try to take multiple courses as you can
your first quarter or anything like that
you might you know get turned off from
the entire program so definitely pace
yourself take breaks in between quarters
if you need it and you know just think
about it as being a longer term invest
rather than just one-quarter investment
that's great Kobe do you have anything
that you would add to that no no I
agreed them completely about the
longer-term investment these courses are
very intense and the teaching team puts
a lot of effort into making sure that
they're it's a really unique experience
for you so you're not just gonna be
doing problems out of the back of the
book you'll be very engaged so I'm gonna
agree with them completely it is a
marathon could you both maybe tonnes
talk a little bit more about the kind of
workload that you that you you
experienced and what your typical week
like is like as a CPD student yeah so
I'm taking one class so I'm fixing to
start up one class right now but I take
one class a quarter so my workload I
dedicate probably about three days a
week towards you know just this class in
the evenings or so that means attending
the teaching assistants live Q&A
sessions that you can ask it's typically
through Skype or some other method and
engaging with other SCPD students I've
actually been on campus quite a few
times for my last class I did a
presentation here for my first class
here you know I spent an entire month
down here working for a on a Robotics
Competition so my workload is typically
pretty heavy with SCPD I'd say 20 to 30
hours a week is average sometimes
heavier depending on what classes you're
taking okay yeah I would say it's very
dependent on the class you take I've had
classes where there was 15 hours a week
and I've had classes where I was above
30 hours a week the the key thing I
think which was pointed out earlier is
having a study group probably like cuts
or workload down significantly I think
my first few classes I just tried to go
it alone and you know just do it all by
myself
and that probably added like ten hours a
week to my workload but it's it's an
investment of times especially if you're
working and the other thing is if you if
you if you want to take classes almost
everybody I know is taking one class a
quarter so if you're considering taking
more than one class a quarter definitely
like really strongly consider that
decision and make sure you know what
you're getting into before you do that
it's great advice I've got two classes
it sucked so I was here until like 3:00
a.m. for like multiple times a week so
so utilized against it heard it here you
heard it here so maybe building on that
czar could you talk about some of the
common difficulties and struggles that
you see SCPD students facing on your
side oh yeah sure
I think one of the most common problem
is that their CPD students start working
on an assignments
too late start working on an assignment
as soon as it is published and posted
because if you just postponed doing -
diamonds on the weekend there's not how
it works right so on weekends you see
some problem you post on Piazza I take
some time for the teaching of SAP
because they are on the beacons - right
so you should expect some delays and
then you would I mean the other CPD
might complain that hey it's like let's
say five hours I posted my question but
I didn't get any answer yet so try to
start working on assignments as early as
it has published and then the other
thing as they mentioned so I was ta for
two to nine and 2:30
also I took two to one and other CS
courses there are not easy courses there
are intense be prepared for them so we
had like a ton of emails like three
weeks before finals saying that hey I
didn't expect this workload from these
courses may request incomplete may drop
the course this is not something that
usually happened so if you think you
cannot dedicate enough time to this
course just just reconsider your
decision for taking this course we have
as far as I know we have a long wait
list for the students wants to take this
course and they can't be enrolled so if
you think you cannot dedicate enough
time for these intense courses
reconsider your decision thank you oh
did you wanna just so it's not all you
know necessarily doing I think there
definitely like a rhythm and it might
take you to like your second or third
quarter to hit that rhythm but you know
your first quarter you're gonna be
trying to figure out how to balance like
you know what time do I watch the
lectures on do i watch it after dinner
do i watch on the weekends and you're
gonna be trying to figure out like you
know should I start the assignments
early or should I wait till you know
later how long does it take um by the
time I made me hit my third course in my
fourth course I was trying to get into
this rhythm and when you get into that
rhythm like it makes it a lot easier
because you know that
okay the lecture is published Tuesday I
haven't gonna set aside some time to
like watch it Tuesday night I'm gonna
like do the assignment I have friends
here that I'm gonna contact I'm gonna
like post my question on Piazza early
like the it is very very hard and not to
understate it at all um but don't be
completely scared off from it you'll get
the hang of it eventually Nick do you
want to add anything common struggles
that you see yeah sure so I think you
know one of the things that we try to
encourage a lot to help people do really
want the classes is to take advantage of
all of the resources that we publish and
what I mean by that is a lot of the
extra session videos that we record a
lot of the additional handouts and
section problems that we post as one of
the remote students that John Michell
mentioned even though I was an on-campus
student I know a lot of the struggles
around you know keeping yourself
motivated to keep up with the material
especially if you're not attending a
lecture on a regular basis cough-cough
as I did you know regrettably whatever I
graduated so it's all fine but the point
being you know like in in you know one
of our classes CS 106 a or 106 B you
know we have discussion sections every
week that are required for on-campus
students but are obviously optional for
remote students we make videos available
for those and and a lot of times from
feedback from on-campus students we know
that these discussion sections are one
of the single most helpful resources
that we have for students because
especially in computer science practice
is what makes you better at the subject
so even if videos like that are
published and you're not required to
attend a section or watch a section
live-streamed or anything like that
we highly recommend that you you know
pretend that you're in a discussion
section at a specific time or watch the
video as soon as it's published or you
know take advantage of all those
resources even if there's not a
structured reinforced requirement for
you to use them you know we try to post
them for a reason we post them when we
see needs that students raise for
you know oh I didn't understand this
well enough okay well let's try to post
an additional video clarifying that
topic you know a lot of times we see
people you know right before exams or
assignments are due you know they'll try
to binge all the videos and you know I
know firsthand it can work maybe
sometimes but you know a lot of the
times you know we try to structure the
course and the schedule and post
resources in a way that if you can keep
up with the schedule as much as possible
you have a great chance of being
successful can you you say you mentioned
some of the discussion sections how does
has office hours I know it probably
depends on the course but has office
hours work for remote students sure so a
lot of times you know at least in the
experience that I've had we try to hold
remote office hours over Google Hangouts
or queue status if any of you have
experience with queue status where you
can sign up online bol video call you
and we'll help you one-on-one on your
computer remotely just tying back to one
of the things I said earlier a lot of
the time when we're trying to schedule
office hours for students we are eager
to hear from you about how we can
improve office hours times structure the
way that we organize you know how we
help students you know whether it's oh
this time isn't great for me this time
would be better or I had an experience
where you know something you know as a
TA did this and I wish they had done
that we love that kind of feedback to
improve our office hours because you're
the ones that are taking advantage of
them you know we don't have on-campus
students that are taking advantage of
those remote office hours those are just
for you but it really does depend on the
class some some classes will combine
remote and local office hours at the
same time others will have discrete
office hours for SCPD students alone so
it really depends on the course
structure but they will usually are
always eager to hear feedback for how
they can make that better thank you
as our do you want to add anything to
that oh yeah sure I'm specifically for
machine learning course yes two to nine
we're gonna have like a post on Piazza
and asking when is the most convenient
time for you STP dear students to attend
office hours is it like after 5:00 p.m.
or is it early morning depends on what
time zone you are and then we're gonna
pick up the most convenient time that
satisfy you know it cannot satisfy the
needs of all of the sepds students but
at least we can try to
satisfy most of them great thanks and
actually sticking with use all right so
we've gotten a few questions you've been
at ti4 some of the really big courses
can you maybe help you give the students
from the insight into how that teaching
team works because it's a big teaching
team and so just they they can have a
some kind of sympathy to to the the way
your the structure of your team and
thank you
last year we have over 1,200 students
for CS two to nine I guess like 600
students for CS 230 so one thing I want
to mention that I remember the TAS or
teaching a staff to York grad students
so they're not full-time employees
sitting back and behind it they laptops
answering your question on Piazza or on
emails they need to take some courses
they also have some TAS answering their
questions so maybe it will be nice if
you give some time for them to get back
to your questions some decent time some
reasonable time and one is specific
advice for the ones are taking 2 to 9 2
to 1 or 2:30 is that like 4 weeks after
the quarter starts we're gonna tell you
who is your party AES make sure that you
know who's your project here is because
the project here is the one that is
gonna evaluate your project at the end
of the quarter so you will be in contact
with your project TA and also make sure
that look at the course website make
sure that we have a specific time slot
for there CPD's so make sure that you
know where this time slot is we are
there we mostly use zoom for
communicating with sepds students make
sure that you know how zoom works
what's the ID for the TAS for the TAS
and then make sure that you online at
the same time that they are online so
basically the course website and the
Piazza are two main sources that you
should
one more advice that I can give you is
that always be on top of your grades so
basically we try to upload your grades
for each assignment straight after you
probably after you stop into your
assignment am I gonna have like a week
to Grade II and then we publish your
grade make sure that you see your grade
and if you have any complaint make sure
that you we're gonna give you like a
week for the submitting your complaint
make sure that you submit your complaint
in that specific window do not postpone
all of your complaint by the end of the
quarter right it's not how it works we
have like a ton of requests at the end
of the quarter and it is and the best of
your benefit to know what your grade is
for each assignment and if you have any
complaint just submitted right away okay
thank you colby - shark it may be sort
of building on what you were talking
about earlier i really like this idea of
creating a rhythm what were some of the
ways you know that you've gotten help
from your boss or from family members or
from friends have you reached out to
them to help support you - I mean to
accomplish a 20 you know there's
essentially a part time job on top of
your full-time well my supervisor was my
exam Proctor most of the time so he was
fully aware of what my course load was
and there was a time where we were
working seven days a week so of course I
had to take some time out of work to
actually complete this coursework so
just keeping them engaged and I'm
married as well so when I was traveling
quite a bit my wife was always like it
is traveling all the time now you're
doing schoolwork we don't really get a
lot of time together so you know it's
just about having that open
communication and you know kind of
planning your actual schedule so some of
the things I did to plan the schedule
where you know talk talk to the teaching
assistants how long should this homework
be taking if I'm extending them beyond
this time go looking for help or
something and you know just plan your
day around that I guess
[Laughter]
yeah to build on that communication is
obviously very very important like me
make sure you're possible you're doing a
course and you know that it's gonna take
some time I think like one of the things
is at the start of every quarter you're
gonna get a syllabus and it'll have you
know here are all the important dates
here the exam dates here are the
assignment dates I throw all the exam
dates and stuff into my calendar just so
you know there's no surprises later on
you know my your your manager hopefully
can see your calendar and they know that
you're possibly booked for that time
there's also I think one important piece
of advice I got when I started was you
know despite the despite your best
efforts despite your boss's best efforts
and you know the core staffs is best
efforts there might be times where it's
gonna be like I have this work deadline
and I have this you know school deadline
and they conflict and there's just not
much anybody can do and like you planned
in advance and everything and that's
gonna happen and one of the things about
finding your rhythm is just realizing
that that happens it's part of the whole
SCPD thing instead of being a full-time
student and so if that happens don't
beat yourself up over it prioritize like
you prioritize anything else you know
maybe you don't finish every single
question on the assignment right you
just finish the top first five or the
five that you knew or something and yeah
just talk to the core staff and use your
late days so we've gotten a couple
questions about exam monitors I know you
can't answer all those but can you maybe
just talk briefly about your experience
with doing taking exams as an SCPD
student yeah so I had to designate an
exam monitor so I just chose my manager
but I've never I've always taken my
exams on campus so I just come and take
the exam I've taken exam this room many
times in some other rooms and you just
take it with the the students that are
taking it here if you if you live in the
area
I so I use my supervisor I was in
Australia whenever I first started here
in 2016 and yeah so I think there's a
list on the SCPD website that tells you
who you can nominate as an exam monitor
one of those are your direct supervisors
the other ones are like testing centers
and I think a libraries in there is
something
that but yeah I mean so I use my
supervisor worked out really well
it's just engaging with him letting him
know when all the exam dates were and
always blocking out time on his and your
calendar to you know have a plan to
actually take the exam that day but I've
never had any issues with that I guess
okay sorry and Nick sort of keeping
their the questions on on exams how do
you how would you recommend that
students prepare for those kind of big
deadlines in the court or the midterms
the finals or big final projects oh
sorry so um
start early again do not so make sure
that you know when exactly is the meter
specifically for two to nine two to one
and 2:30 and then try to start preparing
for the exams like two weeks ahead of
the exam the exams are not again easy
and then you're competing with the most
brilliant students in the world in
Stanford they are taking the same course
as you're taking and then we are looking
at the distribution of the grades at the
ends right so make sure that you start
preparing for the exams early in the
quarter and we post midterm questions
like a week before the exam make sure
that you went through that practice
midterms and make sure that you know
what you are expected in the exam time
also view post the largest sticker of
the exams like two weeks before the
exams make sure that on the Piazza make
sure that you read off them and there is
no surprises on the exams I okay do you
have anything sure yeah so I think there
are a couple things that I've seen over
time the first one is you know a lot of
classes have review sessions outside of
their normal class time and so for that
reason you know it's not something that
everyone can attend you know whether
you're on campus or where your remote
you know you can watch an additional
video but one way or another I'd highly
recommend taking the time that the
course provides you to kind of reflect
and rehash all the material that you've
already learned and take that chance to
reach out to the
core staff if you have any confusion or
you know misunderstandings about any of
the course material we do our best to
try to mark a period of time in between
you know assignments and in the midterm
where we are eager to answer as many
questions as we can and say hey try
these practice problems tell us if you
have any questions or are confused and
along those similar lines try to form a
study group either online or in person I
know you know from personal experience
study groups are like the bomb because
everyone's like oh you know that half I
know this half I love you you know you
can study together so you know and then
it'll all work out except I'm not
condoning cheating no I'm not but the
point is that you know if you get
together with somebody who's really
solid on one subject and you're really
saw it on another and you can help each
other out whether it's meeting in person
and doing problems together or even
something I've done in the past which is
teaming up together and making an online
study guide together and saying hey why
don't you try to fill in this part I'll
fill in this part and then we can go
over and discuss the material together
so having it having somebody to bounce
ideas and challenges and questions off
of whether it's the teaching staff or
another fellow student I think is really
helpful common exams I'm fantastic we're
nearing the end and so I actually just
some of the tips that you've provided I
was thinking and maybe as a kind of a
final take away what would be especially
in these first two weeks what would be
the one or two things that you would
recommend all students do in those first
two weeks I think the the number one
thing I recommend is talk to your
professor and your teaching staff just
as a person not in an academic setting
just introduce yourself your background
what you're interested in why you're
here why you're doing this I think you
know a lot of things make you as a crowd
unique but one of the most interesting
things is a lot of you are doing this in
a professional setting you're doing this
to achieve professional goals or do more
in your workplace or work on projects
that you couldn't previously do before
we love to hear about that you know it's
different when you're a student
obviously you're a student working
towards a full-time degree and you
obviously have a lot of interest as well
but you know you as a crowd are you in a
unique position where in a lot of cases
you're applying what you learned
directly in a job that you're doing at
the same time and we there's nothing
that makes us more excited than hearing
about oh you know I learn about this and
you're
lecture last week and then this week
like you know we were working on a
project and you know I got to apply what
I learned or you know if you have an
open-ended project in a class and you
decide to you know incorporate some
aspect of your work in that project and
have kind of hit two birds with one
stone
that is fantastic and we love to hear
about that so it you know it really
makes us excited
it lets us connect with you so I'd
highly recommend you do that do you have
any other examples of sort of the key
contributions the way in SCPD student is
really added to or increased the class
experience for themselves and other
students yeah I mean we I mean obviously
you all have a really unique background
where in a lot of cases you have more
experience either from you know past
degree standpoint or an industry
standpoint where you know we've had
Piazza discussion groups as others have
mentioned you know where we've seen SCPD
students chime in with like oh well in
this background that I had from a
previous degree I did or this job that
I'm doing or something like that
they'll chime in with this amazingly
relevant answer to a question or
application of some concept that we're
learning so you know your background is
and your experience is one of the
biggest assets that you have and you
know nothing makes us more gratified
than to see that kind of shine in a
class setting fantastic sorry is there
what would be the one thing that you
would recommend everyone do in these
first two weeks probably for many
courses for many CS courses you need to
pick the topic of your project in the
early weeks like first two weeks or
three weeks make sure that you pick an
appropriate topic for your project don't
be too ambitious make like a decent goal
and make sure that you know you're
teaching a staff very well make sure
that you know their resources make sure
that how you can see your grades how you
can ask the question how you can submit
your homeworks and just be on top of
everything in the first two weeks of the
quarter if you have any questions just
send us an email or post on the Piazza
I'm able you be more than happy to
answer you Thank You Koby I guess my
advice would just be to read the
syllabus so a lot of courses use their
own platform
it's Python MATLAB or or something like
that I've seen a lot of SCPD students
wait till like oh three days before the
homework to try to install all this
software and order their textbooks and
oh it's not working or the textbooks not
coming until the day after the homework
just read the syllabus you're a distance
student so you might have to take a
little bit more initiative to get some
of these softwares and books before the
other students do yeah two things I
would say is one the study group you
know this is actually a great
opportunity you're with a bunch of
people that are probably taking some of
the same courses that you are there are
also SCPD students maybe try to find one
or two people that you can go study with
when the semester the quarter starts and
then the second thing would be like when
the first lecture comes out early next
week try to watch it as soon as you can
it's very easy to fall behind and very
very hard to catch back up if your two
lectures behind or something so yeah
just watch it as soon as you can that's
fantastic and that's a perfect segue to
Shara thank you very much I want to
thank our panel first of all so if we
didn't really come as sushar said this
is an amazing opportunity we're going to
have a reception right now so this is a
chance both if you have more questions
to reach out to SCPD staff there are
student client services here they can
answer some of your questions John not
mines in the back and the white shirt he
sees well you can ask him your questions
I hopefully didn't send too many people
doing right away and as well as some of
the course advisors for I believe CS and
EE will be there some of our panels will
be there and as again as sushar said I
think most of you have written your
course and and your your where you're
working on your name text this is a
great way to go out there and see and
meet some fellow students to build those
connections and to check that first
thing off your your checklist which is
forming a study group so follow us you
can follow us up to up the hill to a
four way Panama and yeah we look forward
to seeing you there thank you